네 안녕하세요 기술로트 알렉입니다 바이브 코딩 빌더분들을 위한 가장 쉬운 웹배포 버셀 클라우드 플레이어 넷 리파이 발음은 넘어가시구요
자 버셀이나 클라우드 플레이어나 넷 리파이가 좀 유사합니다 서비스 레벨로 배포를 해주는거죠
요 이전에는 클라우드라는게 있어요 지금도 잘 있고 클라우드라는것은 AWS, GCP, Azure 가 있구요
저는 여전히 유의하다고 생각합니다 그런데 만약에 아주 아주 간단한 웹사이트를 만들었다
그러면 이것을 굳이 클라우드를 알아가면서 하는것보다는 쉽게 페이지 레벨로 배포를 해야하는 것이 가장 쉬울 수 있어요
그 대표적인 서비스들이 이거 말고도 꽤 많아요 엄청 많죠 사실은 대표적인 것이 이 정도 되는거고
버셀이나 클라우드 플레이어나 넷 리파이는 이런 페이지 레벨의 배포는 되게 좋은거 같아요
아주 초기에 바로 내가 만든것을 테스트 겸 배포를 한번 해보고자 한다라고 하면은 이런 서비스들을 이용하는 것이 굉장히 쉽다라고 생각이 됩니다
페이지 레벨이라고 하는 페이지는 보통은 html, css, javascript까지라고 보시면 됩니다
웹사이트를 만든거죠 배포도 너무 쉽습니다
그냥 폴더체, 드래그앤 드랍으로 서비스에 올리면 돼요
이거 한번 간단하게 해보겠습니다 저는 클라우드 플레이어로 했는데 버셀이나 넷 리파이도 상당히 비슷해요
거의 서비스를 이용하는 수준으로 가능하다
DNS 관련되서 한번 간단히 설명을 좀 드리겠습니다
도메인이라는 개념은 익숙하게 사용하고 있죠
HTTP로 시작을 하고 있고 이렇게 이름 이 도메인에 해당이 됩니다
HTTP는 일종의 규약이고 통신 프로토컬이에요
HypertextTransferProtocol이라고 해서 이렇게 html을 주고받는 또는 api를 주고받는 약속이 HTTP입니다
많이 타이핑을 해봐서 익숙한데 이게 프로토컬이다 라는 거고 이렇게 웹서버와 데이터를 주고받을 때 사용하는 프로토컬이다 정도로 이해하시면 되고요
서버로 접속을 하려면 결국은 필요한 건 뭐냐면 IP입니다 IP라는 피도 프로토컬이거든요
IP라는 것이 인터넷 프로토컬인데 이 IP가 있어야 많이 IP를 알아야 많이 서버로 접속을 할 수 있어요
그것도 한 약속이죠 그래서 서버에 이런 IP가 있는 거고 이 IP를 찾아가다 보면 해당 서버로 도착이 되는 거예요
그럼 이 IP를 알려면 어떻게 하냐 그때 도메인 name 서버로 호출이 되는 거고요
도메인 이름을 가지고 있는 서버인데 이 IP를 가지고 있습니다
그래서 어떤 도메인들에 대해서 쭉 나오고 이 도메인의 주소가 뭐다라는 것들을 기억하고 있는 것이 도메인 name 서버이고요
이 도메인 name 서버를 호출해서 이 도메인 name 서버에서 실제 IP를 가져오는 행위를 한다는 거예요
그게 브라우저 상에서 이루어지는 거죠 브라우저는 도메인 name 서버를 거쳐서 실제 IP 이 서버의 주소를 가져오는 행위를 하는 거고
이 실제 IP를 알게 되면 이 IP를 내통망을 지나서 실제 서버까지 접속을 하게 되는 거예요
이건 예를 들면 IP고요 이렇게 쓰여지진 않을 겁니다
실제 IP로 접속을 하는 과정이고 이 IP에 해당하는 서버에서 예를 들면 웹 서버가 구동이 돼 있을 겁니다
웹 서버가 구동이 돼 있으면 이거는 대부분 80 포트를 사용합니다
그러면 웹 서버 기동되고 있으면 얘가 응답을 이렇게 주게 됩니다
웹 서버는 이런 정적 파일들 html 이미지 이런 것들을 가지고 있다가 응답을 해주는 그런 단순한 역할을 하는 것이 웹 서버입니다
이 뒤에 와스도 있고 db도 있고 한데 일단 웹 서버까지만 기억을 하시고
웹 서버를 접속해서 데이터를 가져오는 과정에 이런 도메인 name 서버가 있고
이 도메인 name 서버에서 IP를 알려주기 때문에 접속을 할 수 있다 이런 흐름을 한번 기억을 해두시고
이 뒤에 영상을 보시면 조금 더 이해가 되실 거라고 생각이 됩니다
클레오드 플레어로 한번 올리는 거 해볼게요
이런 것을 좀 만들어 봤는데요
어떤 유형의 앱을 만들어야 될까 라는 생각을 할 수가 있잖아요
이 얘기는 제가 따로 올릴 테니까 요거는 그냥 이렇게
아직 가입을 안 했다면 아마 가입부터 하셔야 됩니다
가입은 그냥 보통의 서비스 가입하는 것처럼 하시면 돼요
가입을 했다면 이제 이런 account 홈이 나오고요
저는 이런 이메일 주소가 보여지네요
여기서 이제 한 페이지, 페이지 올리는 거니까
다른 내용들은 천천히 한번 보시면 되고요
컴퓨터를 누르시면 워커스&페이지스 있습니다
페이지스로 들어가셔서 페이지로 올리는 거예요
저는 이미 하나 올렸기 때문에 이렇게 보이는 거고
두 개가 보이는 거고 만약 새로 올린다 그러면 create application
단순 페이지예요, 지금 html 페이지이기 때문에
페이지 디플로이드에서 참냐 라고 하는 여기를 선택을 합니다
drag&drop으로 이 files를 get started 하는 겁니다
그리고 app name 같은 것들을 지정을 하는 건데
여기는 그냥 구분을 위한
제가 이전에 app type 만들었으니까 app type 2로 만들고
create project 하면 되죠
create project 하면 됩니다
그러면 app type 2.pages.deb이 생긴 거고요
여기에 files을 올리라는 거예요
그러면 이렇게
여기는 folder
folder라고 하니까
여기 체로 이렇게 올리겠습니다
그 상위 folder
그러니까 folder 체로 올려라 라는 차이예요
그렇을 때 업로드가 다 됐으면
디플로이드 사이트 가보면 됩니다
여기에서 이렇게
그러면 페이지가 잘 올라간 게 보여지네요
이렇게 해서 페이지가 올라갔잖아요
그러면 궁금한 거는 이 URL을 쓸 수도 있어요
이걸 그대로 공유해서 누군가한테 주면 이 페이지 들어와집니다
이렇게 서비스 하는 것도 문제가 없을 정도예요
이렇게 하시면
내가 따로 도메인 구매 안 해도 되는데
대개는 도메인을 구매를 하잖아요
도메인을 구매한다는 것은
내가 특정 이름의 도메인들을 사는 거예요
가비아가 우리나라 국내 도메인 구매 사이트 중에 대표적인 거고
카페 24 이런 데도 있고요
이랬을 때 내가 도메인 원하는 거를 치는 거예요
그거는 제가 이름 짓는 거죠
그래서 구매를 하면 됩니다
이 가격들을 보고 구매를 하면 돼요
네임칩 같은 해외 사이트를 이용하기도 합니다
도메인을 구매한 뒤에
예하고 연결하는 부분
그거 한번 보겠습니다
그거는 다시 워컴트 홈으로 가보시면
이제 컴퓨트의 워커스 앤 페이지스
그러면 지금 앱타입2로 만들어진 게 보입니다
여기로 딱 들어가면 됩니다
커스텀 도메인스라는 메뉴가 있어요
커스텀 도메인스에서
이제 셋업, 커스텀 도메인 하는 거예요
그러면 내가 연결하려는 도메인이 있을 겁니다
이런 식으로
저는 앱타입점, 테크노트점, 위키 이렇게 했어요
본인이 연결하고자 하는 도메인이 있을 거잖아요
여기 연결해주면 돼요
저는 이미 연결을 좀 해뒀기 때문에
여기서부터는
각자의 도메인 이름을 여기 입력하고
연결하기를 누르면 연결이 됩니다
여기서는
HTTPS까지 적용을 해줘요
도메인은 그렇게 연결을 하고요
SSL 적용도 필요하죠
SSL 적용은
여기로 다시 들어가 보시면
만든 타입2
도메인의 도메인의 도메인의 도메인
같은 타입2
여기에 커스텀 도메인스
여기로 들어가셨을 때
SSL까지
인증이 될 수 있게 연결이 됩니다
계속 진행을 하다 보면
여기까지 하고요
저 같은 경우는 기존에
제가 연결을 해놓은 게 있어서
한번 그걸 보겠습니다
앱타입으로 원래 썼고
여기까지
앱타입점, 테크노트점, 위키
보이죠?
연결이 된 건데요
커스텀 도메인스에서 SSL
이내블드라고 표시가 됩니다
그러니까 아까 연결을 하면서
SSL까지 적용이 되어지는
진행이 됩니다
물론 이것은
마지막에 퍼징이라고 해서
퍼진다 해서 퍼지는 아니고
퍼지는 시간이 걸립니다
그래서
그거는
하루가 걸릴 수도 있고요
기다리면
접속이 될 수 있게 된다는 거예요
그래서
간단한 페이지를 만들었다면
그 페이지는
이렇게 서비스를 이용해서
배포할 수 있다라는 개념
SSL까지 인증이 되고
자기가 구매한 도메인도 연결이 되니까
그렇게
한번
이용을 해보시는 것도
좋을 것 같습니다
오늘 간단하게
클라우드 플레이어의
웹을
배포하는 과정
배포라고 하는데요
페이지를 올리는 과정을 해봤고요
이렇게 해서 접속할 수 있다
이렇게
배포하는 과정
이렇게 살펴봤습니다
이러한 내용이
유익하셨다면
좋아요를 눌러주세요
그럼 제가
이런 관련된 영상을
꾸준히 올리도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다